ua
ああああああああ
バッハ
膵臓ロケットですよこんちゃー外れたそうですあーおれは今起こってラッツ休み中に
推奨の血糖を上げて動画を出したと思うんですけども
今だ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
姉実は商品が間違っておりましてみなさんがしっかりしたスイスロケットだったんです
よもっとなんかすごい威力がちょっと水素ゲットだったんですけども商品を送って
くださる会社が水ね違うロケットがところでらしくてすいませんでちゃって電話が
かかってきて餌が少しの返金と本当は遅れはずだった商品を送れば
言われていればダンボールで物が届いてことに来た
んですけどもうのそう品がこちら間違えたそう品と同じです
同じは抹茶このうちちゃんと生徒を組み合わせてと送ってきたからまた間違いだったん
です+がのゴッドの俺もこれは許せねえ
外でここにあげたやつの中相殺落下してさあもっ
何もうまくいってないよながんまくてねサーについて攻撃違うなったですよねどうやっ
てな
もうもうもうもうもう no 8もう水するけれども嫌だこれ飛んだよ僕が欲しかった
また違ってセアの外で打ち上げた時に失敗ですと同じやつでございますもーっ
家でやることにしたどうせ一発電所も知ってるよ踊ってちゃんとやっていく
ブーブーこれまあ n 2連勝
全部英語なのでなかなか難しいですいくぜ
いい感じじゃないでしょうか
[音楽]
voodoo
me
ふふふ
を
ねーなーっ
me
car
いっ
と夕食でリベンジしてみたんですけどもうまくいきませんでした本当に申し訳ないです
全部説明書英語だから何か僕の手順の店があるかなと思って
今回入念にちゃんと説明書通りに作ったんですけど本当に上手くいかなかったので多分
家やならないのかなって思いました
何がダメだったんだろ本当に水の量も完璧にして
時間
も全部完璧で守るべき所は全部持っていったんですけどもうまくいきませんでした
どうなっているんでしょちょっとほんとわかんないたぶん次
たぶん次に飛ぶときは自分で水素ロケット作ると思いますじゃあな